humans seem to be the only species on
earth that can really harness the power
of creativity with some pretty decent
results maybe you've heard of flying the
internet the first personal computer
cinema renewable energy the sistine
chapel atomic bombs youtube landing on
the moon vaccines even if creativity
becomes a part of our lives is it our
jobs to make it digestible for other
people what's the value of a creative
idea if it can't be shared if you want
to know more about it make sure you stay
tuned and watch till the end
[Music]
before going to sleep i like to close my
eyes
and imagine how something that i
designed would manifest just doing it
for the sake of like going into my own
little space and enjoying it any idea
that comes out of
an elusive process like this
will require
a lot of convincing so you enter into
this big atrium
and the client's just going to be like
okay that's interesting but you saw it
in a dream hey guys welcome back to the
channel if you're new here my name is
dany and i am a licensed architect in
beautiful vancouver bc
on this channel we talk about creativity
architecture and design and some tools
and strategies for us to have more
creative and meaningful careers in
architecture sometimes creative ideas
speak their own language and actually a
lot of the times the world is not ready
for it so how do you draw the line so to
speak and
how do you decide when an idea becomes
worthy to be shared with the rest of the
world
robert e franken defined creativity as
the tendency to generate or recognize
ideas alternatives or possibilities that
may be useful in solving problems
communicating with others and
entertaining ourselves and others i
really like this definition because it
implies that you kind of need another
person to appreciate a creative idea
this is also the reason why a lot of
remarkable people with amazing ideas
spend most of their lives in solitude
defined by society as outsiders or
freaks i'm hoping to extract an
algorithm to define the movement
but
all they really needed was a pair of
eyes that could see the world the way
they do isaac newton struggled a lot
with criticism and he refused to accept
or be accepted by the scientific
community of the time he started helping
out a pharmacist called william clark
and he was given an environment where he
could cultivate and improve his skills
he was given the freedom to test out his
creativity now fast forward to his
college years
an astronomer by the name of edmund
halley stopped at cambridge university
for a lecture and those two connected
and the result was the publication of
principia which is a book that pretty
much revolutionized the scientific world
for the next 200 years but you might be
saying you're talking about friggin
isaac newton like i was a freaking
genius the fact that you are a different
person and your life is made up of
unique experiences
will induce unique thoughts and the
potential for creativity
all of these processes will trigger
parts of your brain
that are always going to be unique to
you to a certain degree in other words
try to see something from a different
perspective this is a very common
expression people use when you're trying
to bring something creative outside of
someone you could also describe this as
a visualization process a brain is like
a calculator that's programmed to
constantly change in real time
based on our previous experiences or
tastes or social interactions
every piece of information is going to
be disassembled and reassembled in a
infinite number of ways
and a lot of the times you can get some
pretty interesting ideas but only
sometimes it can lead to really
meaningful results
that's why it's important to distinguish
between creativity intelligence and
productivity
creativity is being able to see
something in a new perspective and make
serendipitous connections between things
that may or may not make sense
intelligence is using knowledge to make
rational and useful actions and
productivity is a tool that you need to
bring your ideas to the masses imagine
these three elements as powerful
chemical components that when they're
combined together can produce explosive
results
creative behavior is represented as a
combination of knowledge imagination and
evaluation which is basically the
ability to examine the pros and cons of
a particular idea or a situation when
knowledge imagination and evaluation are
multiplied by a positive attitude
that's when new creative ideas can turn
into something meaningful and have an
impact on the world
turns out creativity can also be
extremely entertaining to watch does
this sound familiar youtube needs
creative people and it's constantly
improving their systems to keep them
productive and loyal to the platform
introducing the youtube algorithm
youtube channels are proof that people
will never get tired of watching new
content is it really that easy to become
a successful creator there's around 2
billion active users on youtube
and there's approximately 45 million
channels and from those 45 million
channels
only
230 000 have more than 100 000
subscribers
0.53 of the channels become profitable
channels it's cool to be creative but it
takes energy it takes time and it takes
commitment to be really successful
leonardo da vinci who is considered the
highest example of the creative mind had
a very relatable problem when he started
his career money he wanted to have an
unlimited amount of time to work on his
theories and his creations
but like the rest of us had a very hard
time finding access to resources to
accomplish that uh 30 year old leonardo
da vinci decided to write a resume to
one of the wealthiest men in europe
ludovico ilmoro duke of milan in that
letter he didn't include any detailed
drawings or abstract ideas or
lengthy textual descriptions the entire
letter was a one-pager with an
incredibly modern value proposition
in just 11 points he described the
fields of applications where his ideas
can produce incredible results the
cherry on top of the cake was a free
trial offer to prove thy he said i am
most ready to make the experiment in
your park or in whatever place may
please your excellency in the end most
of architecture is kind of the art of
convincing a few wealthy people to spend
millions of dollars in your buildings
and the marriage between ideas and
persuasion is kind of what makes or
breaks architecture by the way i also
made a video about how to create
effective presentations if you're
interested i'll leave it right here
here's a portrait of a man who had so
many navs that he decided to put a metal
plate under his arm chair so that he
could wake himself up by the sound of
his pen falling on it
it seems a little bit counterintuitive
that albert einstein had
so many unproductive habits but einstein
himself claimed that a lot of his
creative ideas came from a half awake or
half a sleep state
he became the most influential physicist
of all time by letting his mind make
serendipitous connections or by
taking unusual perspectives on very
complicated tasks a lot of great ideas
do not come from inside your head but
from the outside and social interactions
scientists for example rarely have the
aha moment alone in the lab
and instead most of them happen during
meetings when they're sharing their
discoveries johnson also mentioned that
every great idea is basically just a
reiteration or a variation of an
existing one that someone already
brought to life the video you're
watching right now is a direct evolution
of a system called the television
this principle is called the adjacent
possible if you want your creative
thoughts to be productive you need to
find a way of confining them in a
controlled space and time
instead of unleashing an uncontrolled
form of creativity and being labeled as
the work weirdo
try to introduce a more logical approach
in the following simple steps being
open-minded with a positive attitude
use different points of view
process unusual ideas without judgment
be persistent in translating creativity
in workable solutions if you have a
really crazy idea use your more tangible
and practical skills to make them more
palatable and always have a plan b or c
or even d just in case your bravest
approaches are a little bit too brave
and lastly
let your mind fly high like a kite
the how can we say that but as steven
johnson said don't give your kite
unlimited rope because sometimes
letting your thoughts fly at a limited
altitude will help your ideas exist in a
possible world
being a creative thinker needs time and
energy
maybe your key to success heights under
something kind of weird that you barely
understand the biggest lesson that the
internet gave us is that no matter how
crazy you think you are
you're really
never alone
videos like this require a lot of work
so if you guys like it and you want to
see more content like this don't forget
to subscribe smash the like button and
hit that bell so you will get notified
when uh when there's new content thank
you for watching and i'll see you in the
next one
high as a kite
it's like hey
[Music]
you